tracts à la main autocollant sur la
veste ses membres de la cgt essaie tant
bien que mal d'interpeller les passants
près de la gare de montigny le
bretonneux
le service public c'est le bien de ceux
qui n'ont pas bien rassembler devant
l'union départementale de la direction
du travail
il dénonce l'austérité qui touche leur
ministère presque 2000 postes supprimés
en france depuis 2009 285 en ile de
france et bientôt quatre supplémentaires
sur le département des yvelines
les agents de contrôle qui contrôlent
leur secteur géographique donné le
secteur vont automatiquement à
s'agrandir et du coup les agents nouveau
pouvoir rendre service public de qualité
aux usagers puisque on aura de plus en
plus de travail on nous demande de faire
quand même le travail qu'on faisait
avant avec 20% d'effectifs hambourg en
dix ans et à un moment donné on ne peut
plus fonctionner être décidé avant la
présidentielle ce mouvement était prévue
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des régions
la récente victoire d' emmanuel macron
ne semble pas les rassurer le nouveau
président prévoit de réformer rapidement
le code du travail qui dit réforme et
diminution du code du travail dit
forcément pour nous agents chargés du
contrôle de ce code plus de difficultés
et puis plus de problèmes à venir
contacté par nos soins la direction
régionale du travail n'a pas donné pour
l'instant de réponse à nos
sollicitations